歡迎收聽古來,我是謝孟公
本集節目由台灣啤酒贊助
老實說最近這天氣熱到誇張
加上磐石忽高忽低
每天盯盤盯到眼睛乾
收盤後最爽的瞬間就是打開冰箱
拉一罐台皮雲泡深啤酒
它那個泡沫冒出來非常的綿密
減糖低熱量一口乾下去
直接把今天磐石凌乳的心情洗乾淨
爽度超高
而且台皮這次搞了一個蠻有意思的活動
完全打中我們這些喜歡大賺一波的人
其實起到9月29號之前
只要買雲炮或是指定的台皮商品
把發票拿去台皮LINE官方登錄
就可以隨機獲得台皮AI虛擬裝備
像是怎樣 買個啤酒都可以打RPG課金解任務
重點來了 你第一期指定的裝備組合之後
就可以參加大獎抽獎
這次最大獎直接抽元大0050 500股的等值現金
兄弟們現在0050一股多少錢
500股送下來也是一大包
直接幫各位的持股倉位補血
如果是喜歡現場聽音樂爆汗的
也有火球技術的門票可以抽
還可以每天加碼抽LinePoints
喝個啤酒可以順便抽0050
這算下來實在是蠻香的
有喝啤酒習慣的人發票記得留好
活動資訊跟連結放在資訊欄
有興趣的可以自己點進去看一下
最後溫馨的提醒
禁止酒駕未滿18歲禁止飲酒
移動到雜晃之後
覺得整體的體驗是有舒服一些
果然可能像是那種鄉下語言又不同
然後又比較傳統的地方
對我們這種家庭課來說
還是心理負擔會比較大
因為真的也不想要影響到別人
可是問題就是
當小朋友年紀還小的時候
他們就一定會發出一些聲音或什麼
所以我們就會很緊張
那我們去餐廳
我們都會盡可能的找有包廂的餐廳
但好在就是至今遇到的日本人都是非常的好
他們也不知道怎麼會有一種那種很有趣的習慣
就是每次吃完飯之後
他們就一定會拿玩具出來給我的孩子挑
幾乎每一個那種有包廂的餐廳
他最後面都有玩具可以給孩子挑
所以這一點算是還蠻不錯的
到雜晃之後就重新回到市區以後
整體的放鬆感就整個拉上來了
不然說像是這邊的餐廳吃飯
你就不會怕吵到別人嗎
因為是市區
你就看大家都有帶小孩
所以也會比較歡騰一點
就沒有什麼太多的心理壓力
然後也很幸運的看到有一個SASICAYA
只要賣大概台幣五六千塊
也有想說這什麼東西
所以就立刻開來喝
但是一個小遺憾是沒有在這邊看到
傳說中的TAKAHIKO
TAKAHIKO他的酒其實不會太貴
他出廠的價格我記得好像是
大概換算台幣是
可能兩三千塊以內左右那只是當然在海外就被炒到一個非常恐怖的價格就是往十倍放上去雖然以絕對單價來講還是沒有很高但是因為你知道它本來只要這個價格
你竟然給我翻的快十倍賣
我覺得太過分了
所以就想說在當地有沒有機會
但他們想說應該是要在5月4初的時候才有機會
如果你再玩的話一般來說就買不到
終於在一個義大利餐點就有看到
哇靠他的酒櫃裡面有Takaigo
直接跟他說我要買這一瓶
那他就想說這個not for sale
然後想要推過其他的
所以就有小小的遺憾
沒有喝到在北海道這邊的一個傳奇酒莊
但當地的一些產品其實也都蠻不錯的
不然像當地的啤酒也都味道是挺好的
後來我們就是花了蠻多時間
像是在什麼大碗百貨
然後或是當地的Outlet走來走去
這邊Outlet我發現裡面有非常多的氣溶珠的機器
它也有寶可夢的Mezar Star
但是我兒子已經算是退坑了
完蛋了這一點可能跟我蠻像
就是一個東西它玩到極限
因為他後來就是包含說
像裡面各式各樣的寶可夢發出的聲音
他都可以去識別
裡面的屬性對客或什麼的
因為本來是一個3歲的小孩
他也搞不太清楚
可是他後來變得超級熟悉
當這些東西他都玩透之後
他竟然就不玩了
我們知道有蠻多的那種什麼專家學者
就是在同個領域一直轉一直疊
然後變成是master
像我兒子就是跟我的特性一樣
反正就是他大概知道在玩什麼東西之後
他就會頓時的失去興趣
現在興趣就已經轉向氣龍珠
氣龍珠就是比較可惜
我從小的時候比較沒有認真去看他
可能是因為裡面的角色不對味
我就感覺每個角色好像都長得很像
反正都是肌肉棒子
所以就沒有特別喜歡
但我兒子是非常喜歡七龍珠
他現在就是整天在
會看七龍珠相關的內容
或是看到機器他就說要打
但是我發現他的快感的來源
可能還是來自於七龍珠的卡牌的收集
當他拿到裡面一些那種超強的卡牌
看起來超級帥的
他就非常的高興
他就是想把所有的譜卡都丟掉
就跟他平常在玩寶可夢卡一樣
這一點可能我後面還要再稍微的訓練一下
其實我最近想要稍微的去改一些方針
因為我覺得我們可能蠻多是這樣子
我們當爸之後我們就會覺得說
小時候可能有遺憾的東西
沒有買到的東西
你就希望給孩子
可是當你把這件事情做到一個極限之後
你會發現你孩子喜歡的東西
會從玩遊戲或是玩玩具本身
變成是買東西這件事情
我覺得這是不行的
所以最近就試著要去把它調回來
然後看了一些網路影片的家長分享
我覺得蠻有道理
他們就想說像我們的爸媽以前就想說你看那個兒子小時候玩什麼樹葉跟樹枝或什麼電池就玩得很高興其實他們沒有騙人他們並不是真的在霸凌你或欺負你
是因為當時的物資條件可能真的也沒有這麼好
所以他們不會刻意的去買很多東西
就像我們家這樣子
新東西就想要立刻買給兒子
可是我們就會在一些小玩具上面
然後找到自己的一個小天堂
就是可能會去假設電池是什麼格鬥選手之類的
小朋友的想像力真的非常的厲害
如果今天你給他一堆玩具的話
會變成他好像就沒有辦法
真的去建立一個他很喜歡的東西
他會變成是他享受在
一直買新東西的過程之中
然後可能不一定學會珍惜
所以這一點可能是現代家長要去克服的
就是每一代家長可能都有東西要克服
那現代家長就是
因為我們的物資是相對豐沛的
所以就會變成可能最後面會讓小朋友的
多巴胺的受器有機會提早就變成玩壞掉
這個是非常恐怖的
所以我們不能夠一股腦的就是
我們都會講說我們不喜歡長輩
以前會講說我是為了你好
現在你的想法其實也是一樣
我是為了你好
你看我買這麼多玩具給你
你怎麼都不珍惜
沒有就是我是為了你好
這個想法本身是錯的
我不能有這個想法
要試著去
怎麼講
一部分的是因材施教
另外一部分的是
我覺得要讓他懂一些蠻基礎的價值
還有我們小時候是怎麼樣獲得一些快樂
要盡可能去複製
雖然物資條件提升了
可是還是要去稍微的控一下那個threshold
就是不要讓自己衝過頭
這個人是最近自己在磨練的一個課題
但整體回到城市之後的體驗真的是極好
突然間覺得對北海道的分數就達到很高
本來在鄉間的時候還是真的壓力有點大
現在的想法是有機會還會再回來北海道一趟
可是那是為了看學
或是可能為了去買到相對便宜的Takaiko
那已經是一個怎麼說是貪小便宜的行為了
因為我老婆講說你整天買那種奇怪
有的沒有東西價格都高多少
你跟我講這瓶多少
這瓶才就算人家那種黃牛家家賣才1萬塊
為什麼你不要買就算了
我說不是那是一個態度的問題
因為今天如果是另外一瓶
那本來就超級貴的
然後你給我一個Markup的價格是可能12%
我就吞了啦
反正我就沒關係
因為我真的買不到
我就跟你買
可是問題是你一個東西是2000塊的東西
你要賣我一兩萬塊
我就覺得很過分
我就覺得Markup實在太過分
我覺得我買我就是一個盤子
所以就會有一種堅持
因為我老婆就問說
為什麼你一直在找這個東西
它又不是特別貴
就直接買就好
你就省下這個麻煩
我說那是一個感受
但高機率回去就還是會妥協因為反正想好的東西就一定要嘗試到我最近有一個很棒的新的發現在這邊稍微跟大家分享一下其實本來是一個靈感就是當我今天看著
因為你知道有孩子之後
你的手機的照片變超級多
或是真的那種宇宙多那一種
然後你iCloud的容量也會直接在網上升
這些照片就是時不時的
還是會拿出來稍微的整理一下
但那個數量真的是非常龐大
我就想說有沒有辦法
就是在每個照片上面去下一些註解
因為有一些那種非常特別的時刻
就像幾天前兒子就突然抱著我睡覺說
他不希望大魔王來找他
希望說我永遠可以保護他之類的
然後就開始在講一堆他對大魔王的看法
跟他的恐懼講一講他就睡著了
我就拍一張照片說
如果這邊可以寄下來說發生什麼事情
那就太好了
所以我就立刻跑去問AI說
有沒有這種很棒的筆記跟日記軟體
他說iPhone裡面就有一個Journal可以下載
我還真的不知道這個東西
我就立刻的到App Store找到了Journal這個App
那真的算是很簡單
可是我覺得很直覺加方便
你可以去寫每天的日記
然後附上附圖
或者說直接拍張照片
tag在裡面
這些照片
就算你是可能用這個app拍的
你也可以後來再把它存到你的
相機的存檔裡面
接著它會附上一個地圖
在地圖上面會給你一個大頭稱
告訴你說這是在哪個地方發生了什麼事情
哪一天
總共寫了多少字之類的
我覺得這是一個非常棒的體驗
之前從小算老師覺得跟你講說要寫日記
但因為別人叫你寫的
我們大家都知道說你一定不會認真寫
可是當你自己有靈感想要去寫的時候
那個感受是不一樣的
最近也跟師傅
我講的師傅是我們在北海道的一個司機
只是在中國這邊
因為他是中國的算是移民
他們都把男性的勞動者就稱為師傅
不然像是送外送的
或是這些司機就稱為師傅
師傅其實在過去的陪伴算是不錯
他就是話多一點
每次問他一個東西就要繞250圈
然後之後再講回我們的重點
但整體來說是一個非常nice的人
所以像我們去吃一些餐廳
我們都會邀請師傅
他都會很不好意思
可是他最後面都還是在加入
但是我覺得他們中國人
有些講話的方式也是蠻特別的
他說謝先生我不跟你客氣
我一定是想吃什麼點什麼
他就會把話說的很滿
然後讓你覺得說OK
我就知道你這樣沒錯
你就想點什麼點什麼
然後最後他媽吃一口飯
就說OK他吃飽了
所以就是一個非常客氣的人
可是講話還是非常的豪邁
最終我們還是有帶著他
就是吃各式各家的餐廳
有一些就感覺他是特別的喜歡
你可以感覺到說特別高檔
他一直都想要吃
之前有幸跟著一些客人進來過
非常感謝我們邀請他
我心中就覺得非常
跟他聊天之後
他就有聊到說他有一個12歲的女兒
這個12歲的女兒現在已經不會跟他講話了
所以在車上有時候我們兩個兒子在吵的時候
我們就跟他說不可以這樣
這是手術的車子沒有禮貌什麼的
說沒關係你就讓他說話吧
有時候過這個村就沒這個店了
我就問他說這是什麼意思
他說因為他現在還是會很懷念他的女兒
還是小BB的時候
然後他跟他說爸爸我要抱抱
爸爸可以幫我抱起來舉起來
爸爸可不可以跟我聊天或什麼的
然後現在這個女兒是已經不會跟他講話了
然後都在跟當地的日本朋友就融入了
他並沒有覺得自己是移民
因為從小就在這邊長大
所以就比較沒有跟爸爸對話的機會
他說其實你們要好好把握現在
其實真的大家都跟講一樣的東西
只是在當下你還是會覺得煩躁
媽的你話怎麼這麼多
你可不可以安靜一下
餐廳可不可以不要一直動
像我們就會拿出育兒神器iPad
我知道很多家長是反對這個
但因為在我們的觀念
可能跟日本有點像
我們是怕麻煩別人大於一切
所以就是給小朋友看個15分鐘的iPad是OK的
當快失控的時候就把東西給他
那就發現他立刻的安靜下來
所以我們會盡可能的不要去影響到別人
但還是希望孩子可以發展的好一點
所以該講話的時候該怎麼樣的時候
都還是可以有他的自由
只是有時候太多的時候
還是會心中會有一點反彈
說你怎麼可以畫這麼多
可是當晚上睡覺看到他們的臉的時候
又會覺得早知道就讓他多講一點話
所以就把這些感受
就全部都寫到了Journal裡面
我覺得是一個極好的體驗
我這邊分享給大家可以找一下這個APP
我真的蠻推薦的
可以把一些一天之中發生的事情記錄下來
就像我記錄的時候還順便寫說
像有一天我在操作的時候
就早上還是弄了一些股票
然後就算是做了一些蠻韭菜的行為
然後覺得自己是白癡
覺得自己是不是
媽的今年不要做股票
收一收回家好了
然後隔天買的東西直接開燈
然後就突然間覺得
好像什麼事情都沒有做錯
就那種情緒的一個反轉
有時候把它寫下來
可能有不一樣的體驗
這可能就人家講的那種交易日誌
以前會稍微去做一點紀錄
因為你會發現說人會忘記蠻多事情
然後sugarcoat這些不錯的事情
會導致說你的思想會有點偏差
所以把它記下來
可能真的對自己會有蠻大的一個幫助
大概這樣子
好接下來我們來進入市場話題
我其實覺得算一下盤面
感覺還是比較震盪一點
但其實已經蠻有資格
就是去發展下一波多頭了
我感覺有一些事件
然後跟開出來的相關數字都還蠻不錯
首先我們先來看一下
Amphlopic跟Salesforce的一個合作
他們想要鄭重推出了Cloudforce這是什麼東西呢這個就是你未來可以直接在Amthropic的介面裡面去使用到37個Skills就是37個Plugin這個是來自於Salesforce
把他們的銷售或是說企業管理相關的內容
整合進去anthropic裡面去做使用
反之如果你今天是在Salesforce這邊的介面的話
你可以使用到它後面的模型是based on Anthropic
它雖然還是有跟蠻多模型商合作
但現在可能會把anthropic的一些強大的模型
作為預設的一個選項
在相關的訪問裡面
就是這兩個人兄
Anthropic的Dario
然後跟Salesforce的Mark
他們都有上Cramer的節目
然後聊到
其實根本就沒有Suspocalypse這件事情
所以其實我們最後面講了一整年
當下一直試著要跟大家說
其實你不可以這樣子一概而論
當然有些軟體在AI的出現
它會被競爭掉
那是肯定的
就像是有些硬體
它可能在AI的環境之下
它照樣是起不來
不是說什麼你可以很簡單的把它分成是軟體跟硬體一刀切
然後接著誰就是一定會怎麼樣
等人一年之後大家就直接從Dario的口中得知
就是沒有Saspokalist這件事情
當然有些人一定還是會想要熬說
這是一種什麼行銷的說法
我就覺得不能夠這樣子一刀切
因為嚴格上來說巨頭也都是軟體
難道巨頭都要去死了嗎
難道所有的價值一定會在模型層嗎
不一定
其實我是覺得每個地方都有它的價值之存在
只是在價值的分配上面
它會有大洗牌這個是肯定的
這件事情給我們的一個啟示
我覺得Salesforce真的是一個蠻厲害的企業
雖然它的產品其實在業界的評價
我感覺大家都不是喜歡他們的
都是比較偏向是有蠻多的維持跟抱怨
但因為它真的掌握了大量的企業數據
跟過往在經濟上的一些know how
所以它知道你們是怎麼樣運作
它也知道法遵是怎麼樣去搞
你說發別要去切這塊可不可以
其實也是可以
但是問題就是說
它一定是有某一種進入門檻
就是不要把一些AI native的廠商
想像程式他們是無敵的
什麼事都可以做
光是你要不要把數據交給Ampropik
可能很多人都會想要打一個問號
特別是他們自己本身
老闆的一些行銷術語
雖然大家已經開始熟練了
但之前的那些行銷術語
一直想要掌控大家
告訴大家什麼是對的
只有它是對的
或是說只有它可以成為是尖端的AI lab
其他人可能都不行
所以他希望美國政府去做管制等等
這些開始去引起一些反彈的說法
你說大家會願意去把自己的資料
交給這樣子的公司還是說他們會寧願有一點的自主性即便他其實就是把資料交給另外一個公司也就是留在Salesforce上面或甚至現在蠻多人在推廣的其實資料應該是要落地要佔領這邊
所以光是這一點
它其實就形成了一個蠻大的進入門檻
就是每個生意其實都是有它的know how在背後
然後再來有蠻多是建立在信賴的基礎之上的
所以他可能不願意把一些東西交給這些廠商
特別是雖然他現在有非常漂亮的run rate
然後再來就是營收跟獲利的增長速度也都蠻好的
但確實它沒有一個長久的track record
你也不確定說在這波浪潮之後
最後面可以活下來可以佔好的東西是哪一些
說不定你可能今天想在anthropic上面去建立你的東西
但是你很快又想要再換去openAI
假設openAI後面有很好的表現的話
或許你現在要把東西放在Salesforce
Salesforce後面可以去串各式各樣的模型
這就是一個最優解
所以要去考慮這些點就會知道
其實軟體它不會是被一鍋端的狀況
它不是suspocalypse
這也是講了很久的一個概念
終於是等到這些企業的大老闆自己出來說
包含像是Dario直接說
根本就沒有suspocalypse
它應該是一個正合的
大家一起受惠
再來就是Mark直接提到說
其實它已經在過去的數十年
被講了好幾次
就是它的軟體要不行了
但最後面因為它畢竟是一個Founder
然後開啟Founder mode之後
其實我覺得他們轉換速度超級快
他直接在第一時間就放棄掉了介面層
直接把他的東西轉到後面的應用跟行動層
我覺得這個是非常聰明的
所以未來在介面層跟模型層這邊
就是會交由這些新的AI公司去拿
可是在行動層這邊
因為他對於企業的know how的掌握還是非常的強大
數據是放在他這裡
誰有數據誰就有黃金
你知道這講了好久以前大家講大數據
誰有數據誰就做在金山上面
可是以前你不知道怎麼去用這些數據
現在有AI之後你懂得怎麼樣去用這些數據
接下來就是進入到如何拆帳的一個範疇
我稍微去查一下兩家公司的一些說法
或是對外的資料
看起來它是兩筆帳單
如果你今天是使用CloudForce的話
當然你去使用AI
你每次的問問題
你每次的支用你都需要去付錢
可是如果說你今天有去用到
Salesforce的API的話
這個就是另外一筆帳單
另外一邊要去做付錢
再來就是如果你今天是在
Salesforce裡面去使用到
Amphorotic AI的話也是一樣的道理
除了付本來給Salesforce的錢
再來就是可能每次的提問
它會有一個類似 package
它可以算說你是什麼樣的方案
我就可以給你用多少的額度如果要去多使用的話也要再多付錢所以看起來是兩筆帳單這邊看起來就是有點那種表面上是和諧是一個合作但後面一定有蠻多的競爭會出現
這也是我們很期待的
雖然我自己目前壓會覺得
迎面可能會在Enthropic這邊多一點
就是誰會獲得比較大的定價權
誰會變成是一個包套方案下的老二
就是比較小的
這個可能就是決定的
到最後誰可以獲得最多的利潤
我們目前猜WizEnthropic
會掌握比較多的利潤
可是這邊還要再看說不定最後面數據的影響超出我們的想像
因為現在所有的這些大模型他們在爬都是公開數據
可是那些閉鎖的數據企業的數據
他們可能不確定或是說不相信這些新的AI Frontier Lab
所以他們不願意放在那邊
說不定後面價值的產出反而會落在Salesforce這邊
所以這是後面的一個看點大概是這樣
再來Marvel上修了他的財務預期
這裡面包含的我認為最大宗一定就是XPU
可能他從Google這邊拿到的一些案子
前面可能是Design Win
然後等到它開始要放量轉ASIC要出貨的時候
就會交出蠻不錯的一個成績
但這個成績其實它沒有辦法很明確的
在某個時間點告訴你說是怎麼樣
就是要稍微的到已經是
算是塵埃落定的很確定的才可以知道
所以下去改應該就是說有些產品
它已經開始會看到大量的晶片會往市場裡面去跑
然後再來就是它上修的很大一環是在講光通方面
它提到說它的一個很大的推力是來自於
SkillUp的光互聯交換晶片
這一塊是Matt Murphy
也就是CEO所提到在後面的一個很強大的成長動能
其實已經蠻多人在前面就讀說
Marvel的DSP或是光通相關的東西
在這一次的電話會議裡面會去做上銷
然後現在看起來就是確定往這個方向
這也是這一波反彈的一個最主要的主軸
就是大家注意到光通的股票是跑的特別的強勢
蠻多都已經進入到新高
所以就是看說這份電話會議
有沒有辦法成為一個催化機
然後持續的再去推升
這些光護鏈相關的概念股
不管是從最上游的材料
然後到中間的什麼封裝什麼有的沒有的
因為這個都算是在未來
假設你要把這些XPU或是GPU去roll到市場上的話
你必須要有這些元件才可以去
完成一個伺服器機櫃的出貨
這個東西算是後面的一個非常強大的戰略物質
光通也是在前面修正了很長一段時間之後
所以我家終於重新的醒過來
在多份電話會議裡面的加持之後
有望可以去看一下這個族群
有沒有機會再去往上推
再來我們來看一下NVIDIA這邊
首先我們要先去看一顆OAI的Halapeño晶片
這個晶片當時在準備要發報要去做的時候
我們就稍微的跟大家聊一下
然後現在是他讓SemiAnalysis進去跑測試
然後跟大家說這個晶片非常的強大
如果你今天去看它什麼Token Per Watts
或是一些在推論方面的表現
它是比GP200 300還要強大的一個晶片
所以就發出了這樣子的文章
然後大家又再一次的可能會對NVIDIA
產生一些懷疑之類的
我們先說這個晶片的測試算是蠻功勻的
但是它有一塊稍微忽略掉的
應該也不是說它是故意的
反正像它大家都聚焦在推論
你要知道這個晶片它其實最主要的用途就是使用在推論
所以若今要去做那種訓練
那種比較暴力的算力用途的話
可能還是會稍嫌不足
但在推論的表現是非常好
只是問題是像它在NVIDIA這邊
其實晶片也已經迭代到VR-Rubin
根據它在電話會議裡面的說法是
從下開始要很快的RAM上去
而且可能是他過往產品線裡面
Ramp最快的
所以就是跟AI模型的競爭一樣
反正每一代出來
就是有人會告訴你說他東西最屌
然後接著下一個人說他東西最屌
所以最後面你就頓話
因為好像每個人都說自己的東西是最強
他們也沒有說錯在當下的這樣子
像這個競爭環境就是
可能不知道
就每一兩個月就有新的東西丟出來
所以很快的你腦中真的會
你已經忘記說誰是最強
反正就永遠都有一個更強的東西
那也因為這樣子就不要去看低一些
就是當下好像是在跑分上面跑輸了
就像現在在模型界大家就看Google沒有
但其實Google在Flash的模型上面
表現都還是蠻不錯的
說不定它跳帶3.5-4
然後接著又攪出一個很暴力的成績
大家又忘記前面是怎麼樣唱隨Google的
一樣的道理
現在大家看到Halapeño很好
一定也會有一些疑恩論的產生
就是會不會NVIDIA在後面會持續的去
Lose Share
或者是會在AI的競爭裡面
開始去居下風
但我覺得是沒有這樣子的一個問題
特別是像Jensen他也在Kramer的訪問裡面
算是用一個很和善的語氣
但是充滿威脅性的提到說
其實像我們的晶片
雖然你有這麼多的XPU加在市場上跑
但是我們在AI的Share都還持續的增加
他其實是沒有說錯
而且其實NVIDIA有一個很暴力跟變態的點
是我們大概在幾個月前有跟大家講到說
我們有注意到說NVIDIA去採購的一些
光通或是雷射相關的元件
那個數量其實是遠超它的東西
所需要的一個數量
當時在節目有丟一個問題出來就是為什麼他會這樣子做最後面我們的判斷是他這樣子做的原因是他想要把對手給擠出去這個開始也變成一些白賽的論述也就是說你現在其實要去做出一台伺服器
你要的是所有的 supply chain都要去跟你合作
你要拿到這些零組件
你要有組裝的能量 光通的元件
交換機什麼的 你全部都需要有
你才有辦法去組出你的東西
可是問題是我們現在都知道說
在AI的各種元件裡面
特別是像NVIDIA這次的電話會議也提到
什麼東西都在缺
他笑談說之前他只要去跟誰吃飯
然後公司很快就會漲一倍
所以他不願意直接去點名說哪個環節
現在是很缺貨
但是其實每個環節都在缺貨
這個在我們家看來也是
最缺貨的環節目前就是在載版這邊
我們注意到有一個非常大的缺口
特別是在接下來開始去討論說
如果記憶體它要從12Hi變8Hi
甚至下有一個新的說法是說
會回到4Hi
這個我還是稍微打一個問號
但假設這個說法為真
它代表的意思是什麼
就是說他們現在要的是記憶體的頻寬
容量可以稍微的折衷一下
可是問題是容量我們都知道說
在KB Cash上面它還是非常的重要
那這時候會怎麼做
它可能就需要一個更大的板子用量
這樣子整體的出貨的數字就會跑得更好
但問題是現在板子本身就是一個缺貨的主軸
所以我認為說記憶體去改這個
然後大家說是因為價格
是因為缺貨
所以我這樣去做調整
但它只是把缺貨從A移到B
就是你還是會缺貨
因為你要的板子的面積是更大
這些板子
或者說像剛剛前面所提到的一些
光通相關的元件
其實NVIDIA它都有一個非常強大的採購地位
它Secure超級多的產能
所以重點是你們現在看到這些很酷的XPU
持續的推出
他們有沒有辦法拿到這些產能
它會是後來的一個大新聞
就是現在可能比較少人去討論
但後面它一定會變成一個大新聞
就是可能它會一直出現地言
它東西不一定推得出來
因為他根本就沒有辦法去取得這些產能
NVIDIA可以取得的主因是因為
他一次買超多
而且他可能是不計代價再買
他在台積電這邊可能是輸了Hard Run
直接嚇到爆掉
所以你們要去跟他搶這些東西
算是非常的困難
他光是可以把供應鏈卡好
可能就可以產生一個非常巨大的競爭優勢
所以你突然間好像看懂
就是可能Jensen他有時
每次跑來台灣吃飯
以前大家都以為說他來吃飯吃
他就是喜歡這邊的料理有什麼
好像突然看懂這是一個局
他布的非常深
然後他確實是把這些供應鏈
全部都牢牢的攔在手上
所以其他人想要去跟他競爭或許是一個非常有挑戰性的事情我自己也這樣相信然後再來就是在這次的電話會裡面他們也有去revyce CPU這一塊CPU算是NVIDIA後面也會變成一個蠻關鍵的業務
現在已經開始攪出很不錯的營收
後面也會持續的去往上拉
再來就是在connectivity
就是跟MARIO一樣
我覺得也都是給出很bullish的訊號
在光通方面也都是持續的看好
在GPU這一塊我覺得以下NVIDIA的狀況來講
他應該會很希望開源模型會表現得很好
因為開源模型他們基本上是沒有太多的
那種first party ASIC的一個能力
所以他們就使用這種通用的GPU
所以這些東西只要越好
越來越多人需要去train或者去做推論的話
他們就會買越來越多的GPU
所以就會獲得巨大的優質
但也不是說這些first party
或是這些closed model這種
必鎖模型像是什麼OAI或是anthropic
他們對NVIDIA需求就不會大
這個還是非常大的
即便說像anthropic這邊有用AWS東西
OAI這邊有現在要用Halapeño之類的
但他們可能在訓練這一塊
都還是要大量的倚重NVIDIA的東西
如果說後來在自己的Custom XPU方面
遇到了出貨卡關的話
也有可能他還是要再去買更多的NVIDIA的晶片
所以即便我們現在單純的去用一個投射來看的話
大家都知道說在接下來的幾年
其實ASIC他會持續的去GAM試戰
因為沒有辦法大家都往這個方向去推
比較大家的這種東西
它本來就是會被大家去吃事戰
只是問題是吃事戰的同時
你要知道整體的市場的TAM是持續的變大
所以它理論上還是會去抓到很多的價值
只是吃事戰的過程有可能的稍微被高估一點
因為大家忘記一下在供應鏈這邊
其實是超級缺貨的
你的東西好就算很厲害很強大
可是如果你沒有辦法找到人家
幫你把整套東西做出來的話
你還是競爭不贏NVIDIA
再來就是如果你真的有辦法
就像說我付更多的錢
我去搶產能我去做
可是如果說你對供應鏈的管理是不夠熟悉的話
你的東西稍微有所遞言
就連NVIDIA我們都可以很常看到說
什麼VRRubin因為某個東西怎麼樣
所以它可能數字約在往後拉
往後RAM的時間約在要拉長之類的
何況是你根本就沒有什麼供應鏈管理經驗的
等到你把東西整個做出來
說不定人家又準備要跑去下一代了
這個是現在非常變態跟恐怖的地方
然後再來就是
就算大家供應鏈都很順好了
可是NVIDIA它是一次賣很多人
他賣了這麼多錢拿來投入他的研發
然後跟後續的各種開發
可是你的東西你可能是自己用所以它是一個效率的提升它是省錢但是你不一定有這麼多資源可以持續的丟下去競爭所以如果我們今天去看In the long run就是如果長期來看的話其實我覺得GPU
還是有非常強大的一個競爭優勢
它並不會因為
現在市場上大家看到說
有很多ASIC
以後春筍磚跑出來
然後所以就代表說它不行
就是說我反而期待的是
我們看到ASIC跟GPU
現在都要去強調
可能在台國市場
又會產生很多新的機會
包含說像這些
前面所提到的光通 板材
或是一些伺服器組裝所需要的東西
大家要去搶的話
當然他就有可能會在繼續的漲下去
我覺得很恐怖
只是理論上我們都會知道說
在工序方面
最終他一定會走到某一個價格的平衡
價格需求的破壞
到時候可能大家就會重新去思考
我是不是願意要去花這麼多錢
其實我覺得在記憶體這邊
現在就是看到有這樣子一個情形
所以他們才會開始去探索說
我是不是要去dispack
因為就是卡住了
他也不是說什麼
他不願意付記憶體的錢
其實就成如馬斯克所講的
我看到AI成長率是200%
我看到你記憶體輸出容量的速度
可能是幾十%
你當然會漲價
就是他可以接受這件事情
但是我覺得馬斯克算是一個腦袋很靈活的人
其他老闆他可能就會去思考說
我不想要像馬斯克這樣
很暴力的去rollout他的伺服器
我可能可以去思考一些方案
然後讓財務數字更好看
讓我的股東可以交代之類的
因為跟馬斯克
因為類似暴君的形式是不太一樣
所以他們確實就會開始去思考說
這個東西如果卡住
我會不會有一些alternative的解放
會不會其實我在宰版這邊
雖然位置都很缺
但是我可能被漲價的幅度是更小的
所以我反而就想要往這個方向去試看看
他們會到處去鑽到處去撞
所以產生蠻多的機會可以去看
所以目前這幾個地方會議看一下
幾個房間看一下
其實我覺得市場中突然間產生超級多的機會
所以有機會去期待
看有沒有東西要帶頭
然後再拉一個新一波多頭出來
我是很希望這樣的事情發生
這樣下禮拜回到台灣的時候
就可以繼續戰鬥
所以稍微跟大家講一下自己的想法
接下來進入我們QA的部分
第一位Edward
Hi 夢公 感謝您節目分享
從2024年開始聽您的節目
原本是因為您溫柔的嗓音開始每週聽
後來回去從EP1開始聽發現相見恨晚
但後來跟著您的節目成長這幾年也資產翻倍
由於這一代的教育都差不多
所以很能體會一些同樣的家庭教育
讓我對您更加敬佩
可以分享自己內心當初可能對我來說是脆弱的東西
也讓自己的心靈更加成長
但最近曉得面臨一個轉折點
在一家大型半導體外商公司
七年狂賺但不分紅給予
而以前台積同事想邀請我回國
可以知道薪水是兩倍以上
但與小朋友相處的時間可能平日幾乎沒有
目前經濟狀況還過得去
但也想持續增長
想問一下如果您是這樣子的狀況會怎麼選擇
主委不用擔心您替我選擇
只是想聽看看如果是您會怎麼選
因為我不像您這麼會搞股票
本業收入也是蠻重要的 愛您
不是吧 看起來這位兄弟也是蠻會搞的
就是從2024到現在翻倍
算帆貝以2024到現在來說
並不是一個至少在我們身邊
全只是吸油的事情
但是以一個就是你還是要上班
還是要顧其他東西
但還是可以吃到這波資本市場
算是蠻不錯
但也沒有到極好
因為覺得像今年0050就有560%
你什麼事都不用做
你就有560%
所以算不錯
但不確定是不是可以持續
所以他這樣講也是對的
就還是要持續的把一些本業給顧好
如果是我會怎麼樣選擇
我不知道我覺得還是會選擇小孩這邊多一點
只要說我現在家庭的各種支出
它已經不會是捉襟見肘的一個狀態
理論上當你已經有一些閒錢可以去投資的時候
你們應該已經不是捉襟見肘
你應該是就只是想要有更多錢
我只能夠跟你說就是每個人都會想要有更多錢
不管你有多少錢你都只會想要有更多錢
很少人會know when to stop
知道什麼時候要停下來很少人知道
到底財富自由背後的東西是什麼
其實之前跟大家分享過好幾次
它就是物欲的一個下降
它跟你賺多少錢其實是沒有關係的
因為物欲一直膨脹的話
在現代的資本社會很變態的一點
就是你一定有辦法把你的錢花光
絕對有辦法
那抑或是其實像是養育孩子也一樣
你會發現說現代的養育孩子
為什麼會花非常多錢
其實很大一部分是
家長自己想要去滿足自己內心的一些想法
但你是有辦法就是不要花這麼多錢
還是可以做好很多事情
不管是養小孩或者說家族旅遊
或是一些生活中的開銷之類的
但我知道每個人都一定會想要去提升家庭的生活
但我必須告訴你一個現實的事情是
不管你有多少錢
你都還是會有一樣的困擾
你就只會想要有更多錢
像以我自己來說
可能你們蠻多人對我講話就很尊重
您這您
但我就自己就覺得
我自己並沒有說什麼很有錢
或是說很厲害的什麼的
因為人外有人天外有天
所以你永遠都是往上看
你永遠都會有一種那種不滿足的感覺如果你已經可以很明確的識別就是你想要跟孩子多相處一點的話我覺得待在現有的地方或許是一個不錯的選項因為你已經明確知道這件事情了
但如果說孩子對你來說也不是特別的重要
反正有玩到就好
當然會想要往前多的地方跑也是很正常的
所以大概是這樣子
我整個時候一般來講
你已經開始有辦法去累積資產
你慢慢往資產的階級去走
也就是說你的收入的來源
大眾可能已經不會是你的工作的話
理論上你要換取更多的自由
所以如果說你沒有更多的自由
那你可能哪裡做錯了
或是你可能就不小心變成錢的奴隸了
這個也是我在對我自己講話
因為有時候像我老婆也會講一樣的東西
就是說你真的沒有辦法停下來幾天嗎
你看像他這麼多這麼酷的東西
或是像你的兒子
你看他第一次做某一件事情
你竟然跟我說你在工作你在忙
你真的沒有辦法停下來一下嗎
然後這時候就會給我腦中敲了一個警鐘
我就知道說其實我是有辦法停下來的
只是我有一些執念
我有一些那種工作的壓力
我想把事情做好
但我後來發現其實我們身邊絕大多數人
反正就是說基本上是這樣的
真的是跟Andrea的創辦人
在之前有一次的訪問所提到的
他說這已經有點像是一種詛咒了
就是你會注意到
因為他被問到資產相關問題
他說好像20幾歲他就是billionaire
人家問他說你為什麼不要什麼
Lay back然後去Enjoy your life
他說其實他認識的這些billionaire
沒有人是有這樣子的態度的
反而就是那一些不會是billionaire
才會講說我只要賺到什麼錢
我就退休我就怎麼樣
因為你有這個態度
你就不會成為billionaire
所以他算是一個還蠻矛盾
然後跟身為父親們
我們要去挑戰跟解決的東西
所以我也覺得你已經可以明確識別是孩子
那就先孩子
後來再換去別的工作
把孩子大一點
像前面師傅講的
他小孩12歲已經不跟他講話
都不跟你講話了
這時候你再去多賺錢也沒有問題
再來講說我怎麼可以去把這種
內心是脆弱的東西分享出來
其實就是某個程度的
Give zero shit就可以了
就是把自己真的想要講的東西講出來
你知道你這樣做
就是一定會不小心讓一些人難過受傷
可是沒有辦法
因為如果你要很如實的去展現自己的話
你一定會讓一些人不開心
我舉例來說
你今天把全公司的人都叫進一個辦公室
然後你去發表你對公司的感受
你看到你的經理
你平常超堵爛他
可是要不是你真的是想要離職的話
你也不會真的把一些話講出來
就說雖然劉經理他蠻GY的
但我知道他也是為了部門好之類的你這樣講話就超無聊的就代表說你還在嘗話你沒有辦法把所有的事實說出來一樣你把整個家族人叫出來到家族的那種祖先排位前面
然後大家在那邊做大檢討
你看到大家的臉
你可能也不好意思吐槽大家
但我想法是
因為我本來就是蠻有意識的在distance這個世界
distance很多人
不然說我盡可能的讓自己的生活變得更加單純
讓我可以單幹
所以就變成我後面蠻容易的去講出一些東西
雖然有時候自己也會去思考說
說這樣講會不會讓自己的家人
或是什麼太太或誰不開心
但我真的沒空管這麼多
但我覺得以長遠的角度來說
我應該會越來越說
因為有些東西我講出來並不是為了什麼
一土為快或是去抱怨別人或什麼的
我講出來的目的只是因為
我其實一直在做一些自我探索
你知道我節目就是一個獨白
就拿著麥克風一直講
你知道有時候講講我自己就會產生一些靈感
原來是這樣子
就當你已經進入那種心流意識流
在那邊輸出的時候
你就知道原來有些東西我沒有認真去想
但是這樣的一個情形
但當你把這些東西都理出來之後
你還是會拉回來知道說
這個世界就是大家某個程度上
都還是有一些面具的存在
為了讓大家相處的更加方便
為了讓大家不要互相廝殺
不要互相討厭
所以有些東西得過且過
我知道這些東西可能對方也無法改變
你就不用再拿出來一直講之類的
但是在一開始那個探索階段是必要的
你就是必要把所有東西都直接拆開來看
你才有辦法去解釋或是解讀一些東西
或許也是因為這樣子
所以讓一些人有辦法共鳴
因為我相信應該沒有太多人會願意
在一些這種類似公開的場合
然後直接去探討自己
可能內心比較脆弱
或是曾經遇過委屈的東西
因為他也知道說他的主管
他的家人也會聽或什麼的
我怕他們聽到會怎麼樣
可是當你有這樣的想法
你就是沒有辦法講出真正的想法
然後大家講
下面一位
達達 挨大 您好
男友是忠實的乖聽眾跟信眾
有時候都覺得他了解你
比了解我都還要多哈哈
原本以為自己是快樂寶貝
應該會聽不懂
結果意外的覺得很好笑
7月28號說我男友生日
想起來大家幫我祝他一句
小羅吉卡生日快樂
雖然已經過了
但是他最大的願望是被來大念到留言
所以我會繼續努力留到被念到為止
也祝來大和家人所有的聽眾
平安健康快樂樂
聽了100多集再跳回醉心
發現來大的聲線變好多
但還是一樣有趣
好那我們先祝小羅生日快樂
大家之所以都沒有掌握到密碼
原因是因為
你現在的留言時間
因為我下這邊是日本的8點48分
就一大早
所以是台灣的7點48分
然後你又是三個小時前所以是凌晨三四點爬起來留言因為spotify這邊的邏輯就是你流就會直接上線所以難怪你都流不到因為一般我錄節目的時間是禮拜三跟禮拜六的下午兩三點
就錄完我就直接上線了
所以就會變成那個時間留言的人
才會有辦法被我看到
只是以前是apple podcast的話
因為它顯示的時間是不一定的
所以人家就要提前去猜說
是前兩天還是前三天的什麼時間
要有時候你某個時間留言
它就剛好會在我要錄節目的時候跳出來
所以那時候才有個說法
叫留言密碼
那現在已經沒有留言密碼
現在就是反正spotify留言
應該是各位一流
我就可以直接看到
所以就變成是還蠻簡單的
只是你可能完全抓錯時間
好那也祝你們一家平安快樂
下面一位卡瓦主委好
你的節目一直是我跟老婆回娘家車程的標配
雖然他常常聽到睡著
今天8月29號是他生日
特別想謝謝他今年陪我一起創業
能不能請主委用猛男生線
來送到那四個字
I'm cute homo
我也不知道怎麼要送這四個字
祝老婆生日快樂謝謝主委
下面一位 Ryan Young
嗨夢宮我終於知道戒菸後的幸運
已經戒了一個月
繼續加油有了兩條線二寶
但老婆有甲壯線抗禁
希望夢宮後面的觀音大愛
可以保佑我們平安健康一切順利
如果可以的話是女兒就101分以上
難得就平安健康長大
希望你們的二寶可以一切順利
下面一位夢宮真的猛
感谢梦公分享日常跟市场话题
小弟是捏软联盟间上班族独生子
在爸爸过世前错过许多的相处时间
想到应该也有不少人被迫在工作
家庭跟长辈照护间去取舍
那想请问梦公
台湾的长照医疗资源越来越紧
中产阶级负担得起的照护模式
有可能怎么做出来
目前想象要用其他事业
来养这种偏公益性质的事业
感谢回答
祝全家健康平安生活開心
非常感謝這位兄弟
如果今天是講到
中產階級在未來醫療上
該怎麼樣規劃
其實我是覺得後面應該會越來越慘
應該至少5到10年會蠻慘的
然後直到大家痛定思痛開始去改
為什麼
因為其實台灣的健保制度
特別我自己越長越大越來越明白
它有蠻多的問題在
簡單來說就是入不敷出
然後再來就是因為健保的關係
所以像一些可能不錯的醫療
就會被擋在外面
因為你不可以去按照醫生的說法說
你這樣是歧視
怎麼有些藥可以這麼貴
應該讓大家說
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕